first of all thank you for for coming
for this talk
my name is rodrigo multa i will talk a
little bit uh
of the use of buffering language in
retail yes
it's a very applied
example
before i go to code and this thing i
will present to you about mache machida
retail group
in brazil
there are three brands it's samashi
santa maria
and italy that italy i don't know if
it's a
very cool supermarket brand in new york
chicago dubai italy yes and now marshad
is bringing
italian to breeze in sao paulo brazil
next year
january i hope
and here are just some nice picture of
our stories in brazil
and the last one it's i think that's
chicago italy because it's not done
there
and
the main purpose of this talk
is see how we can apply wolfen language
in retail in business yes and we have a
lot of application of buffering language
in masha
and i will divide this presentation
three parts both from scripts
and front end and in the last web
mathematica
here's joshua
fancy visualization for someone who
wants to see the
how is the structure layered okay
here are the brain the main branch of
that
and here is the future i really would
like to make some tests with buffering
clouds because i think that they have a
lot of application reports and these
kind of things
and so on let's start with whooping
scripts yes
today i have
let me come back in here i have it's
more organized here
okay
today this is our github repository for
summaries
for for our script you have 30 35
scripts running in most different parts
of the company yes here there are all
let me take one here
this kind of uh files yes it's the new
one this is the
the old dot aim file that now it's
forefront language officially yes
and
and how it works we have a server in
this server make the automated report
with windows shadow task so i can
program this to every monday send this
report to execute this code not to
report some there are reports but the
most part are etl instructor or you have
web scrapper that goes on some
competitor site take the price and get
it in your database
yes
and these are are they both scripts and
i show we don't have time to to walk in
all of these scripts and some of them
are not so interesting
and i i select some of them too to get a
little bit more in detail
what's the idea here it's how can you
use vuffin language to create automated
reports yes using this kind of script is
in in their server what's the advantage
of buffering for that is that i like to
say that the good reports i report that
my grandmother can understand
just use colors yes and if is some
problem oh my son yes there is a problem
here and how you can do that in
mathematica you can use outliers you can
use the statistical tools to make the
report very easy to read so you go
you have in super market all business
you have a lot of information so
the smart report you can get directly in
the trouble here's the example you don't
need to be expert in this report or
details to
so the idea of this report is it's
if if you read something
you have to pay attention or manager of
this
story has to pay attention in this
number and make some action on that
and we have a very nice
era of distribution of this report so
first the manager of the store if you
just keep it like this so to go deeper
to the
manager of the
a bunch of stores and so on to the ceo
of the company yes and this kind of
intelligence it's it's we have a lot of
things that can be done in this in this
way and here is so if it had you have
some problem to solve here too and this
report is sending all day to all the
manager of the company and you have more
than 10 reports of this kind of things
work like that
and more you can send george when you
have a you don't have to overflow your
team of reports just if you have
outliers same this information okay
here it's um
i have some link here
this is how the hyper is structural so
it's almost i
i follow some some pattern that gets
into the database connection make out
the sequel and take the information
create the report components creates
the report itself and make the
distribution of the reports and bit by
email okay
in future i would like to choose the
now the new notebook template i think
that would be great for this kind of
distribution
this is the first one the second one
is automatic order entry it's a report
very similar so we have a lot a bunch of
outliers here so you can easily
follow trendline see what happens
and easily
discover this we are changed the system
so it's very clear that i have a problem
this week yes
and it can track
easily track information if you have
problem the company or something wrong
you see the pattern of the reports it's
this is a little bit more complicated
because i i have a lot of reports like
that so i use package
so i have the package here with
each one and they'd have a very similar
structure with sql inside it's get sql
make the calculation over it create
report components create support and
send in infinite send it by mail
and price link it's one that was
interesting
in retail it's
sometimes you have to have a
link between this is a very simple
example have much more complicated one
and
each one of this coke
this should be cheaper than the high
coke yes so when you put this in the
database we have a lot of link between
them
and when all this link you can make this
graph
and you can compare how much on each
cheaper the other if they are respecting
the
volumetry of of the item and if there
are some inconsistencies i think that
this was a
strange application of find cycles
that's the new function of version 10 so
i can't have a cycle here because it's
like jesus cheaper than this this this
and go on to the first one anymore you
have a lot of more complication relation
like this one
so i have a cycle here or i don't have
it's not just visible i i have to make
this in automat automatic way and it
mathematically is trivial to to to do
this kind of things
so this first part
it
i would like to show just some bunch
these are automatic scripts so i don't
have to do anything it's just ruined in
my server some for example this price
quite because it's every day
the server showed me with send some
email for
is some inconsistencies here there is a
price that it's cheaper than it should
be so correct this yes
the another block
it's notebook reports
so we have here so
here we have a notebook in this notebook
you have to interact with this to create
something
in this one we did excel spreadsheet
created by mathematica yes so i have
here in windows
it's just like this it's a nice
application of of association
and
this here is our product hierarchical
tree
so each one is uh some lack of i take
association populated with that in the
end and i use this structure
to to make a very simple dynamic
dynamics and create the report i think
that have internet connection here
although from today was not so luck as i
am i think so
dj
yes
so here it's going to my database yes
make some calculation here
and after this it will take the
calculation put in a spreadsheet
and actually now nowadays mathematics is
not so good to make
nice fancy formatting in excel so i have
to
to make a vb script that mathematically
do all the process called the vb script
format this this spreadsheet and and
give the result yes
i think that not to look too
but i have one done here
it's online review
there are just like this
the end
result
so here i have all my products and i
have i have a lot of nice calculation
here to do
the
which major products by quantity by
volume by demand by a lot of of and here
i take some stores i get closer of these
stores i see if the product is the
correct store or or isn't it so it's a
lot of nice stuff
and i just use the b script to format
this material yes
so you have a lot of meeting you oh it's
working yes it's just low but it's
working so it's going database and in
this case here i have
just two two sectors it's whiskey and
leica i don't know like
liquor yes
and in here the in the as the result
is almost done he'll just reproduce the
reports
and people can use in the company
this
next one it was very interesting because
it's very different
this is our meat planogram distributor
of meat in the supermarket so now have
16 stores at the end of year 90 stores
and what's the best way to distribute
this in the shelf
because sometimes come a new guy for
this department you have a high turnover
in the company
and
start to produce all wrong so what's the
best way to distribute these products in
the shelf and give how you have to make
the order of this this production yes
and i have made some calculations in
mathematica to do this
it's the as very nice way to disable
disease
yes and these are the kind of types of
of meeting in the sub type of meetings
in how it should be distributed
on the shelf
i have it i think that affects six month
sales on that to get a robust start on
information and i just put this on the
shelf with some corrections because
sometimes i i don't have this product of
these guys not producing it correctly so
i can't make this error
propagates yes and i have a little
manual
address in in final
but
here i can show you the the codes
it's very
we have all the same same float gate all
my my i have i'll start to get something
of my database yes make some calculation
area of chronogram blah blah and here i
just choose the store in here is the the
design the best design
for that this algorithm has made and you
have rollout in the store it's very easy
to understand and you have discussed a
lot what's the best way to do that
because the the old way was a list and
no one read the list to confirm no no a
picture
just make a picture and follow this
picture so it works very nice yes but
you have a lot of intelligence behind
this picture to make the correct
distribution of the material
and
this is just one more
report but this we use interface with
excel a lot of these information are not
in our database so
it creates a template excel that can be
easily filled so just as a good notebook
let's book make all the rest of the work
and sing sends it's here
and send the email in the file of the
code
it's here
export report
this is one no nothing so yes this is
this one
and you send the report for all the
stuff that should receive this using
excel please
user of my staff to traditional in this
report is an exception when i have to
use notebook i use this this guy has
mathematica to work on that
and
some other studs similar time is okay
says forecast it's it's an interesting
case of using of sarima yes you have
here
the codes so i have to enable dynamics
yes
so here i'm using sarima it's
interesting because and the ceo of the
component shows this oh okay it's nice
but i want to i believe that next year i
i watch a little bit more than this a
little bit mess so here
we are doing this together it's not
completely done he can
play here and put the feeling yeah
sarima do a lot of job and go there and
change okay no problem so you can have
both words to make people use it to to
to these techniques
and here you just cop to excel you have
a copy button here
yes so if you go to excel now you can
paste it the the information yes we have
water make some some tests on that i'm
trying to convince some financial people
that's best used sarima then a lot of
crazy stuff that they do today you don't
understand
sales performance it's a brand new story
that we are doing there too
it's a big challenge to discover
we have the whole company and sales got
up sales gap down what happens what's
the best way to to to see that in in how
it works i'm not getting into details
now because i have a small time but it's
very interesting you can use a lot of
temporal series you can put a special
event here to know uh with some
something happening in some store and
how can i make it really easy and visual
to distribute this kind of information
and search for guests it performs
a little bit
it is the last one from
from
not from the presentation for this one
it's how you study and behavior of our
clients the distribution of your clients
now we have a
relationship program inside the company
and on one question that was very old
inside the company whoa i will be a new
story here
my market team should
work in which area of the company yes
and this was one question the other
question was investors oh you don't need
to open a store like this you already
have one kilometer in store so it's not
necessary so we start to just begin in
the studio of this and you have a nice
export to google earth
so in google earth you can really these
in green are
our stars
here all this is created in mathematica
all the stuffs are the the layers and
exported in
google herbs
so it's it's great because now you can
do things like this here i put the
competitors
and whoa they have a lot of store we
have space to build much more stores in
sao paulo this is the biggest retail the
red one in sao paulo yes and these are
used to investors to understand for
example stores that are very close one
for other
but yes it's a very dense population
zone it's no problem to if it's just one
kilometer of distance of this and all
this is done using mathematica and we
are just a little bit out of the time
and i will show you the last one
that's a completely different from all
these
that the use of web mathematica
that it was for me a surprise we started
to think about this last year here in
the conference
and
how could i do something just like vote
for alpha but for my company yes so
people can ask things in the system and
get some answer and from this you come
with delve it's it's wise alpha and but
i have some problems to have change
without
and
it's amazing because we have this number
of of
search in the system right now last
month 55 000 search in the system and
it's nice because people can just ask
really really simple question like what
was my goal of last year and they have
the answer yes in the system and i can
show you is the last part
the the english version it's brand new
so it's here
so they can do this in portuguese
portuguese much more complicated the
english do that just sales i can say
this in
50 not 15 50 ways just the verb in many
combinations and now the outfits
understand all this combination like a
more morphological analysis that it
worked before the person and here i have
user requests that is very interesting
these are questions that the users are
doing those right now in in the system
so you can see here it's
two minutes ago in in brazilian time is
this this it's what she's asking
it's it's a product chandon have top
sales you have sales sales goals
products plus
fiscal notes and a brand nice
question and is this is what i use for
learning what users are doing and with
this i i create new questions that i can
answer
with the system
yes i can
i have no interpretation my database is
logged so i see i can crunch that and so
whoa this is very interesting let's put
in the system yes
the parser is basically a bunch of
regular expressions today yes and i use
association to make the tag of the
phrase now i i really like this in
version 10 because it's much more easy
to break all my my phrase and use the
association to get the pieces uh and
make the understand on that it's much
more faster and easier to handle
information i'll use a lot of but for
this yes
and
yes thank you
thank you so much sponsor for the third
time the conference here yes
wolfram team the opportunity to present
this talk and i really would like to
thank you john food for undoing very
soon yes